we all know about the pandemic that has
come to define
2020 understandably covid19 has
dominated
the world's agenda and mandatory
lockdowns were introduced in many
countries
to help control the spread of the virus
for many of us
the lockdown was inconvenient we
couldn't go to our normal places of
business
we couldn't visit family or friends and
we couldn't socialize publicly
but for some people though the freedom
to get out of the house
was not just a matter of convenience
but of physical safety and even life for
death
based on my work i see the great
majority of those vulnerable people
are women and this resonates with me
especially today as i give my talk
from the safety of my home as a
practicing obstetrician and gynecologist
i am also aware of the prevalence of
gender-based violence
in communities across nigeria
and this is why i founded the women at
risk international foundation
wharf in 2016 in response to this
global estimates published by the who
indicates that one in three women
worldwide have experienced an act of
violence
and this was before the lockdown in
march
an increase in the number of cases of
violence against women was becoming
apparent
across the world amounting to a shadow
pandemic
that we are now faced with globally in
france for example
there was a 30 increase in the number of
cases of domestic violence
and in argentina emergency calls from
domestic violence cases
increased by 25 percent in the first two
weeks of the lockdown in lagos state
our emergency phone lines ranked
non-stop and we recorded
a 64 increase in calls from women
trapped at home with abusers in fear for
their lives
by june the authorities became aware of
the shadow pandemic
and a state of emergency on rape was
declared by the federal government of
nigeria
as we fielded the distressing calls from
girls and women
young and old we were able to help as
thankfully we kept the warrif rape
crisis center
open as a refuge of last resort
in the more remote areas many women had
to walk
miles to receive any medical care and
attention
as there was no transportation because
of the lockdown
they had no internet access to reach
social media platforms
and they had limited phone services to
call a 24-hour confidential helpline
or even a neighbor so the situation for
these women
was much worse our solution
in addressing this was this there are
over 3 000
traditional birth attendants working in
rural areas
across lagos state today these are
community-based
men and women who have been informally
trained and provide basic health care
to both women and expectant mothers but
none of them had received
any form of training on how to help
women suffering from domestic violence
we successfully trained
1 300 of these community gatekeepers
as first responders in addressing the
cases
of violence against women in their
communities
this meant that during the lockdown they
were galvanized
to go house to house in their
communities and with their training
were able to offer the necessary
assistance to women trapped at home
unable to receive care reports varied
from verbal and emotional abuse to far
worse beatings
and sexual violence but those home
visits
served as an opportunity for these women
to share their stories and to receive
the much needed care and support
that the traditional birth attendants
offered this program
has been rolled out across an additional
seven local communities
and has reached nearly 35 000 people
raising awareness of the shadow pandemic
in these communities
in the months to come we plan on
including our other gatekeepers
the law enforcement officials and the
religious leaders
truly impacting on communities and on
the safety
and the lives of these women as we
embrace the new normal
of working remotely from home and with
online schooling
it is more than likely that more women
will be trapped at home with their
abusers
and this shadow pandemic will persist
but i take hope
and inspiration from the courage and
determination
of the many who work to protect and
support these women
i have been awed by the unbelievable
strength
and the tenacity that these women have
shown during these precarious times
and their ability to find their power in
spite of all of this adversity
so with or without the pandemic the work
to protect
girls and women continues
because every girl and woman no matter
what part of the world she lives
has the right to live in a society
free of any form of violence against her
thank you